Повалені дахи, спалені та напівзруйновані стіни й перекриття
роками ховаються від людського ока
за яскравими рекламними банерами у середмісті Києва
Занедбаними пустками стоять десятки садиб, де жили та працювали всесвітньо відомі українці.
За дослідження і порятунок таких будинків взялися
активісти громадської організації "Мапа реновації".
Разом з волонтерами вони відшукали усі закинуті будівлі
одного з найбільших районів Києва, зібрали вичерпну інформацію
про кожен об’єкт та нанесли їх на мапу.
Ми проаналізували за цей рік Шевченківський район
і виявилося, що в ньому знаходиться більше 200 "заброшок",
а це на хвилиночку близько 700 тисяч квадратних метрів,
і все це в центрі Києва.
І як виявляється, це в основному
архітектурні пам’ятки та культурна спадщина.
Причини та стадія занепаду у віднайдених 226 будівель різні.
Однак переважна більшість з них - у приватній власності.
І на думку активістів, до стану повної руїни споруди доводять навмисне,
аби потім на їх місці звести дорогі квадратні метри житла чи офісних приміщень.
У законі у нас прописано: якщо це пам’ятка, а вона розвалилася,
то вона більше не пам’ятка. Чому у нас будівлі і горять неодноразово?
Вони просто їх палять системно чи вони загораються, неважливо,
і чекають поки вона буде вже в такому непридатному стані, щоб перетворитися на руїну,
позбавитися статусу і на її місці щось таке виростає.
Тому перша причина - це земля,
а друга причина - це сама по собі ціна реставрації.
Вона не дуже вигідна і це завжди має бути командна гра
декількох інвесторів, щоб хоч якось покрити ці витрати.
У цьому будинку, зведеному у 1874 році,
майже 4 десятиліття жила родина Терещенків
Свого часу він був однією із найрозкішніших садиб Києва.
Тепер споруди належать підприємству "Центрелеватормлинбуд".
З кожним роком стан будинку погіршується.
А правових механізмів змусити власників якщо не реставрувати,
то принаймні не допустити занепаду історично цінних будинкі,в в Україні фактично немає.
Усе, що може зробити міська влада, - оцінити стан цих будівель зовні
та звернутися до правоохоронних органів.
Зараз мізерні штрафні санкції.
Коли ми виходимо на такий об’єкт, навіть якщо ми знаходимо власника,
якщо це приватна власність, зареєстрована на фізичну особу,
то це 1700 гривень штрафу. Ну, це просто смішно.
Людина купила об’єкт, довела його до руйнації,
а ще за кошти міста ми повинні зробити йому реставрацію,
відновити і так далі? Продай або віддай місту
і тоді місто буде вкладати туди кошти.
Окрім приватних занедбаними та зруйнованими залишаються сотні будинків,
що належать місту або перебувають у державній власності.
Лише у Шевченківському районі "Мапа реновації" нарахувала таких 59.
У жалюгідному стані, приміром, знаходиться будинок,
де народився і жив відомий авіаконструктор Ігор Сікорський.
Довгий час будівля була в оренді благодійного фонду,
який заявляв про намір зробити в ньому музей.
Однак за 16 років жодних робіт у ній не провели.
Вже п’ятий рік він належить Міністерству оборони,
яке також не береться за його відновлення.
У ще гіршому стані перебуває й садиба
відомого українського художника Олександра Мурашка,
розташована зовсім поруч з Майданом Незалежності.
Те, що пам’ятку архітектури досі не перетворили на торгово-розважальний центр чи офіси,
багато в чому заслуга Олександра Глухова.
Цінність цих будинків, по-перше, з офіційної точки зору
вони пам’ятка національного значення.
Найперше, вони мають історичну цінність, а по-друге архітектурну.
Архітектура тут така еклектична трохи,
а історично - те, що оце саме будинок, в якому жив Мурашко,
там були його майстерня, і от зараз там немає просто даху.
Олександр Глухов вже 25 років живе
у спорожнілому й занедбаному будинку поруч з садибою Мурашка.
Він не погодився на відселення, бо розумів, щойно в будівлях
зовсім не залишиться мешканців, їх можуть зруйнувати.
У 2007 році місто продало комплекс будинків приватній компанії.
На те, щоб повернути їх назад у комунальну власність і не допустити знищення,
Олександр Глухов витратив майже 10 років життя
і взяв участь у 40 судових засіданнях.
Тепер він чекає поки міська влада запропонує йому квартиру
і почне повноцінну реставрацію садиби Мурашка та прилеглих до неї будинків.
Дворик буде красивим, наприклад, тут буде кафе.
Там буде галерея картинна, там ще щось буде.
Це об’єкт, який має цінність туристичну, якщо вже говорити
з прагматичної точки зору, культурну цінність.
Активісти переконані: залучити небайдужих людей
та надати максимального розголосу справі -
наразі чи не єдиний спосіб захистити будинки від повної руйнації чи знесення.
Окрім садиби Мурашка таким чином вдалося вберегти від перетворення на торговий центр
Гостинний двір та комплекс садиб на Подолі.
Ці випадки стають прецедентами і можуть в майбутньому докорінно змінити ситуацію.
Проблема в тому, що у нас немає судової практики по таких саме кейсах.
Слідчі, коли починають займатися проблемою того,
що десь руйнується будинок, відкривають кримінальне провадження,
матеріали до суду і справа розсипається,
тому що немає правових позицій Верховного суду.
В цьому аспекті показовим є кейс Хорива 2,
тому що це допоки єдина справа по Києву за останні п’ять років дії
нашої міської влади, коли було відкрито
кримінальне провадження по умисному доведенню до руйнування пам’ятки архітектури.
У "Мапі реновації" окрім дослідження міського простору
готові на практиці допомагати киянам боротися за старі будинки.
У нас є в штаті юристи. І вони їх консультують.
Перш за все, ми систематизуємо завжди документи по будівлі, щоб розуміти,
наскільки реально проблема болюча.
Ми намагаємося робити просвітницьку діяльність і допомагати по конкретним кейсам.
А друге - це ми нещодавно, ну як нещодавно, вже майже півроку,
навчилися робити охоронні статуси будівлям.
Це дуже гарно працює, коли будівля історична, має цінність
але статусу не має, і вона взагалі не захищена.
Минулого року ми так втратили 10 історичних будівель, і це не жарти.
Це прямо масова епідемія.
Питання руйнації пам’яток архітектури актуальне не тільки для Києва.
Занедбані садиби й замки, які могли б стати туристичними об’єктами,
а натомість поступово занепадають, є чи не в кожному
українському місті та навіть в селах.
Тому активісти "Мапи реновації" планують зробити проєкт
всеукраїнським, а згодом і міжнародним.
У Львові багато дуже будівель, у Одесі.
Я не буду брехати, але здається за один місяць впали три будівлі дореволюційні,
у них є цілий квартал "заброшок" величезний.
Тобто у них також є ця проблема і також з цим ніхто особливо не працює.
І тому масштабувати дуже легко.
У нас вже підготовлені всі інструкції і всі інструменти, як фіксувати це на мапу.
Будинків, які офіційно мають охоронний статус в Києві три з половиною тисячі.
У КМДА покладають надію на законопроєкт про охорону культурної спадщини,
який депутати проголосували у першому читанні ще в 2018-му.
Якщо його приймуть, штраф за доведення пам’ятки до руйнування
зросте в десятки разів, до півмільйона гривень.
А міська влада зможе навіть примусово викупати історичні будівлі у приватних власників.